- OH, OKAY,
I'M BOBBY BOTTLESERVICE,
AKA, BOBBY BOTTLESERVICE.
I HAVE A GREAT DESIRE
TO KNOW THE UNKNOWABLE.
TO SEE THE UNSEEABLE.
TO UNDERSTAND PARALEGAL
ACTIVITY.
AKA, GHOSTS.
[bell peals]
WITH ME, AS PER ALWAYS,
IS MY BEST FRIEND
AND NIGHT-VISION VIDEOGRAPHER,
PETER PAPARAZZO...
- YO, I'M NOT PARTICULARLY
AFRAID OF ANY SPECIFIC GHOST.
- AND OUR DEAF/MUTE
SOUND GUY GIAN.
I MEAN, THIS KID
ALWAYS SHOWS UP.
AND TOGETHER,
WE'RE VERY MUCH GHOST BOUNCERS.
[woman screams]
SO WE RECENTLY GOT A CALL FROM
AN OLD-TIMEY TOURIST LOCATION
THAT THEY HAD FOUND GHOSTS.
SO WE WENT DOWN THERE
TO FIND THOSE GHOSTS
AND BOUNCE THOSE GHOSTS OUT,
BRO.
- THIS BUILDING DATES BACK
TO THE 1800s,
WHEN IT WAS ORIGINALLY
A BROTHEL.
AND IN 1854,
THERE WAS A MASSIVE FIRE HERE
THAT DESTROYED MUCH OF
THE THIRD FLOOR AND THE ATTIC.
- WE WERE VERY MUCH AROUSED
TO LEARN THAT THIS LOCATION
HAD AT ONE TIME BEEN
A BROTHEL.
DUDE, THIS PLACE IS SO OLD.
THERE'S NO, LIKE,
FLAT SCREENS OR ANYTHING.
- YO, IS THAT A GHOST?
- NO, BRO.
THAT'S A VERY MUCH CUTE,
ADORABLE ELDERLY WOMAN.
- SINCE BEEN RECONSTRUCTED,
AND OBVIOUSLY...
- [scoffs] WHAT IS THIS,
LITTLE HOUSE ON THE SCARY?
- [laughs]
GIAN, YOU GET THAT, BRO?
- NOW PLEASE FOLLOW ME
UPSTAIRS.
[woman screams]
NOW, ONE GIRL DID DIE
IN THE FIRE.
[woman screams]
SHE WAS 16 YEARS OLD,
AND AS THE STORY GOES,
SHE WAS ON HER WAY
TO TURN HER FIRST TRICK.
- SO SHE WAS A WHORE?
- SHE WAS, YES.
- BUT IN ADDITION TO,
AS WELL AS, SHE WAS A VIRGIN?
- YES.
- OH, VIRGIN WHORE, BRO!
- PERFECT.
- PERFECT. DUDE!
[snaps fingers]
APPARENTLY THIS WOMAN
WAS A GIRL
WHO WAS ALSO A VIRGIN BUT,
AS WELL AS, A HOOKER
WHO HAD DIED IN A FIRE.
- SOME PEOPLE SAY THEY SMELL
THE WAFT OF A JASMINE PERFUME.
- I VERY MUCH PUT MATHEMATICS
TOGETHER
AND REALIZED THAT THIS VIRGIN
WAS ALSO
AND, AS WELL AS,
THE GHOST.
[woman screams]
WOULD YOU DATE ME?
'CAUSE I THINK I LOVE YOU.
WHY DO YOU LOOK AWAY?
WHY DON'T YOU SMILE FOR ME?
IT TURNED OUT THIS GHOST
WAS NO DEMON.
TSK, TSK, TSK.
SHE WAS AN ANGEL.
- [ghostly whisper]
BOBBY.
[woman screams]